but also thank you for your strong
support to connect with our
transatlantic Alliance in a more
dangerous world it's even more important
that we have a strong bond between North
America and Europe in NATO as we have
and uh the United Kingdom contributes to
our Collective defense in many different
ways you need the multinational battle
group in Estonia you keep the
Skies over our Eastern flank safe with
the UK air policing and then you also
contribute a lot of ships Maritime and
capabilities over Naval emissions and
patrols and then of course the United
Kingdom has been and is a lead Nation
when it comes to providing support to
Ukraine you have trained the Ukrainian
soldiers for many years but now actually
you stepped up of the nation and as you
mentioned I missed the UK training
facility where I met a brave Ukrainian
soldiers being trained by and by UK
trainers but also trainers from other
NATO Allied countries and that shows the
leading role you have in the alliance
and uh and then I'm absolutely certain
that I can continue to count on the
United Kingdom in in a more contested
World
under that we all need to invest more in
our Collective defense in the in a world
where we are more challenged by
authoritarian regime so thank you so
much
lots for us to talk about so let's get
on with it thank you very much United
Kingdom leads our multinational battle
group in Estonia
Kingdom
keeps the Skies over our Eastern flying
safe by being part of our air policing
in the eastern part of the alliance and
a British naval ships are an important
part of NATO patrols
around NATO territory
I also praised the Prime Minister for
the strong supporter of the United
Kingdom provides to Ukraine this morning
I visited one of the training sites for
Ukrainian soldiers I saw uh here in the
United Kingdom and I saw the Brave Young
Ukrainian soldiers being trained by
British trainers but also trainers from
Canada from Lithuania from other NATO
Allied countries proving how United
Kingdom plays a key role in leading our
efforts in providing support to Ukraine
the United Kingdom had done that for
many years trained close to 30 000
Ukrainian soldiers stepped up after
Innovation and the message is that we
need to continue to support Ukraine if
President Putin wins in Ukraine it will
be
disastrous for ukrainians but it also
make us more vulnerable because then the
message to president put into other
alternative leaders will be that they
can get away achieve their goals by
using brutal military force so it was a
good meeting and and I am confident that
I continue to count on the United
Kingdom as a leading NATO Ally President
Putin made several huge mistakes when he
invaded
Ukraine strategic mistakes one was to
underestimate the ukrainians their
courage their commitment to fight and
protect their own country the other
mistake he made was to underestimate
NATO allies Partners in our ability to
support Ukraine and what we have seen is
that NATO allies and partners have
provided unprecedented support Ukraine
and what we see when you look at the
opinion pools the political messages
from different NATO Allied countries is
that we are ready to continue to provide
support for as long as it takes of
course there are always some voices that
have a different opinion and that's
always the case in Democratic societies
but the overall majority the clear
message from NATO allies is that we will
continue to support Ukraine it's our
interest that they win that Ukraine
prevails as a sovereign independent
nation in Europe and when it comes to
the elections in the United States
well it's not for me to go into the
details of those outcomes especially
because there's still counting going on
but it's absolutely clear that there's a
strong buy parts and support in the
United States for continued support for
Ukraine and that has not changed with
the elections that has taken place in
the United States yesterday the United
Kingdom has lead has has led uh by
example over many years when it comes to
also defense spending uh spending more
than two percent of GDP on on defense
the United Kingdom has done that and now
more and more allies are following the
example of the United Kingdom because in
a more dangerous world we need to invest
more in our defense and I'm absolutely
confident that the United Kingdom will
continue to lead by example on defense
spending we have seen the announcement
but we will of course wait and see what
actually happens on the ground what we
do know is that Russia has been pushed
back first from the north around Kiev
then in the East and on car cave and
then actually we see slowly how the how
ukrainians are able to push back the
Russian forces also in the South around
Carson
so
it is encouraging to see how the brave
Ukrainian forces are able to liberate
more Ukrainian territory the victories
the gains the Ukrainian armed forces are
making belongs to the brave courageous
Ukrainian soldiers but of course the
support they receive from the United
Kingdom from NATO allies and partners is
also essential so the support we deliver
including the training I saw this
morning here in the United Kingdom is
essential it will continue and and that
is also the message when it comes to the
situation around Ukraine that we will
continue to support around Carson that
will continue to support uh Ukraine